die Armbanduhr für viele ist die unnötig
immerhin hat jeder ein Handy und darauf
ist die Uhr sowieso präziser für andere
sind sogenannte Chronometer ein
essentielles Accessoire dass sie an ihre
Sterblichkeit erinnert und ihnen
Motivation im Leben gibt für mich
persönlich sehen die Dinger zwar ganz
schick aus aber mein Grund eine Uhr zu
tragen ist dass ich zwar ein Smartphone
habe aber eben nicht ständig
draufschauen will es gibt
massengefertigte billig Ware und
handgefertigte Kunstwerke die schnell
über 100.000 € schwer sind eines jedoch
haben alle Armbanduhren gemeinsam sie
werden von Menschen gebaut die Ahnung
haben von dem was sie tun und das werde
ich ändern indem ich einfach meine
eigene Bau und zwar aus Metall und Holz
dieses Video wird unterstützt von Schub
mehr dazu später wie soll sie aussehen
die Uhr wie er an meiner Uhr seht stehe
ich eher so auf schlichte Uhren
allerdings wenn ich schon eine Uhr
selber mache und quasi jede Form und
jede Gestaltung machen kann die ich will
dann mache ich das ein bisschen
extravaganter ich habe vorhin in der KI
schon ein paar Bilder generiert die echt
cool aussehen aber bei mir alle nicht so
richtig gefallen wo bin ich jetzt hier
im CAD-Programm und ja darf Träumen
okay hier immerhin Sechseck so soll aber
nicht bleiben
und damit wird er zum Stern den will ich
aber nicht so lassen ich will ein
bisschen dreckig
[Musik]
Alternative
ich glaube dass ich das so ziemlich geil
finde hier ja das finde ich sehr cool
zum Schluss konstruiere ich noch den
Deckel in dem später das Uhrwerk liegen
wird das Ziffernblatt ist im Gegensatz
dazu nicht metallisch kühl sondern aus
warmem und echtem Holz wobei das Metall
darunter durch die ziffernblattstriche
hindurchschimmern wird damit ist der
Bauplan für meine eigene Uhr fertig mit
einem eleganten Design das Natur und
Technik in einem Stück kombiniert alles
um dieses Uhrwerk herumbau jetzt selber
stellt sich nur die Frage wie um alles
in der Welt ich sowas komplex ist
überhaupt in die Tat umsetzen soll womit
wir zu unserem neuessten Prunkstück in
der Werkstatt kommen unserer CNC die
kann mit Computer gesteuerte Präzision
mehr oder weniger jede beliebige Form
aus Holz Kunststoff und
leichtmetallfräsen das Ganze ist super
komplett und gar nicht mal so günstig
deswegen ist bestimmt eine gute Idee ist
einfach mal drauflos zu fräsen
langsam der taucht der kommt langsam
oh Gott
also so richtig glatt ist die Oberfläche
jetzt nicht ne was ich euch beim ersten
Bauteil dem gehäusedecke aber noch
verschwiegen habe ist das die CNC leider
nicht automatisch weiß was sie machen
muss man muss fast für jede Bohrung
Kontur Abschrägung oder Einlassung einen
extra Pfad generieren indem genau
definiert ist welches Werkzeug also
welcher dieser lustigen Fräser verwendet
wird welche Abmaße dieser hat wie
schnell wie steil und von welche
Richtung dieser ins Metall gefahren
werden soll und noch viel mehr früher
war das wirklich extrem aufwendig aber
mit moderner Technik bekommen das sogar
hin und das was ihr gerade hier seht ist
die Simulation davon was jetzt gleich
sicherlich genauso problemlos auch in
echt funktioniert wird
[Musik]
so das war jetzt
[Applaus]
so jetzt kommen wir zu dem oberen Teil
also das obere Teil der Uhr richtig
schön sein muss wir sind viel komplexe
das Teil also damit wirklich ewig in
zwei Tage gerade ja darum gebastelt
angefahren
Thomas Philipp warum macht er das der
macht aber auch Sachen die überhaupt
nicht hier drauf sind wenn sie groß
[Musik]
ein bisschen langsamer gemacht das war
50% zu stellen was macht er da
[Musik]
aber warum fährt er doch eigentlich so
nicht
runter
[Musik]
hast du gerade nicht im Ernst am Fräser
eingesaugt
[Musik]
langsamer
ich war das ich war das
Gehäuse 5 mm dick konstruiert aber
leider das falsche Alu Blech eingespannt
das nur 4 mm dick ist
das ist ungefähr so als würde man eine
DIN A4 Seite auf einem DIN A5 Blatt
drucken wollen und sich hinterher
wundern wo der ganze Text abgeblieben
ist aber auf dem zweiten Versuch klappt
es jetzt doch garantiert
[Musik]
als die Hälfte von denen
nein nicht schon wieder ein Fräser da
ist man leider beim zweiten versucht
direkt ein Fräse abgebrochen den wir nur
einmal hatten deswegen jetzt direkt auf
Ebay Einsatz neuer Fräser bestellt und
da habe ich ein mega Tipp bei dem ihr
bares Geld beim Online Shopping
zurückbekommen könnt durch Cashback mit
Schub unserem heutigen Sponsor darf ich
jetzt zum Beispiel einfach über 15 Euro
zurückbekommen als ich mir Luftfilter
bei der Eisen gekauft habe dabei gibt es
über 2.200 Partner wie zum Beispiel
Media Markt Booking.com Ebay oder sogar
Lieferando wo ich gestern bei einer
Bestellung einfach 2 € zurückgekriegt
habe man klickt einfach in der Schub App
auf sein lieblingshop auf ein wie
gewohnt und hält anschließend ein Teil
des Einkaufswerts auf seinem schubkonto
gutgeschrieben
das Geld könnt ihr euch schon ab dem
ersten Euro Cashback direkt aus
Bankkonto oder auf Paypal auszahlen
lassen eure Daten sind dabei komplett
sicher weil schon keinen Daten
angetreibt sondern sich einfach einen
kleinen Teil der Vermittlungsprovision
einbehält sich damit eben finanziert und
ihr bekommt den Rest Schub hat bereits
über 2,2 Millionen Nutzer in Deutschland
und ist damit die Nummer Eins also
klickt jetzt auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung meldet euch kostenlos
bei Youtube an und ihr bekommt 10 €
extra Cashback bei eurem ersten
Einkaufen das heißt der 15 Versuch und
wir nehmen jetzt zum ersten Mal das Teil
hier raus weil wir so zuversichtlich
sind dass es jetzt brauchbar sein könnte
so die spannratzen die kommen ab
oha
[Musik]
das sieht auch total geil aus von unten
einfach
das heißt es sind überall fast durch
aber nicht ganz sieht man hier hier
links ist es ja sehe ich euch durch aber
hier auf der rechten Seite halt leider
nicht deswegen nehme ich das mal mit an
die Werkbank und Schraube ist irgendwie
rauskriegt natürlich aus dass das echt
schneiden wir Alufolie
[Musik]
raus
geil aus
[Musik]
also cool sieht das jetzt schon aus hat
auch die richtige Form aber die
Oberfläche soll nicht ganz glänzend
genug deswegen wird jetzt immer
ordentlich poliert und geschliffen aber
vorher wurde noch mal die CNC
angeschmissen und der Deckel gefräst der
später das Vorwerk halten wird fehlen
nur noch die Bohrungen in die später das
Armband hineingeknipst wird
zuerst wollte ich dir mit der
Standbohrmaschine machen aber da man
eine CNC ja auch manuell mit Pfeiltasten
ansteuern kann habe ich einfach den
Fräser durch einen Bohrer ausgetauscht
und die CNC genutzt um erst die winzigen
Bohrungen zu machen
[Musik]
und dann doch wieder mit dem Fräser
einen Kanal zu fräsen für die Achse der
Krone mit der man bald die Uhrzeit
einstellen kann
[Musik]
als letzte Amtshandlung einer CNC kommt
das Ziffernblatt aus hauchdünnem und
echtem Walnuss Holz und das Messer und
weil das mir zu dünnem Holz so viel
schneller geht haben wir das direkt vier
Mal mit jeweils verschiedene dick
gefrästen Ziffern gemacht aus den ich
dann das schönste aussehen konnte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch eine unerlässliche Sache fehlt noch
womit wir beim Uhrwerk wären quasi das
Herzstück einer Uhr dass die antreibt
teure Uhren haben oft einen mechanisches
Uhrwerk dass man entweder aufziehen muss
oder dass sich durch die Bewegung selbst
aufzieht das ist extrem cool aber eben
auch teuer und filigran die meisten
Uhren haben ein batteriebetriebenes
Quarzuhrwerk und so eins für baue ich
also auch vielleicht kam noch keiner vor
mir auf die dumme Ideen der Armbanduhr
einfach selbst zu bauen weshalb ich die
Dinge im Einzelhandel Links gefunden
habe und mir einfach eins aus einer
alten nur klaut die ihn nur noch Staub
ansammelt
[Musik]
ich habe alle fertigen Teile vor mir und
jetzt muss ich nur noch die Uhr
zusammenbauen ich fange an mit diesem
Teil bzw erstmal mit diesem Teil weil da
müssen jetzt erstmal ein paar Sachen
zerlegt werden erstmal hier raus
so genau er musste hier raus da muss ich
jetzt diese Zeiger muss ich abmachen
möglich zu machen weil die sind super
filigran
das hat glaube ich geklappt und jetzt
hier einmal das Uhrwerk ein mit dem
kleinen Richtung
[Musik]
so das wird jetzt einmal hier eingesetzt
das schon sehr geil jetzt haha ist schon
krass wie das aussieht und obendrauf und
jetzt das Teil hier und ich nur drauf
achten dass genau da wo der Ausgang ist
auch der Ausgang sitzt
[Musik]
boah das ist krass das ist richtig geil
wie das jetzt hier in Kombination
miteinander aussieht das sieht einfach
aus als wäre es ein Teil ich finde das
Ultra schön dann geht's jetzt weiter mit
denen ich weiß gar nicht was heißt das
Drehrädchen das hier durchfädel
so und jetzt bevor die Zeiger noch
kommen kommt ihr erstmal als Holz rein
und das wird extrem geil weil dann sieht
man zum allerersten Mal wie das aussieht
die Striche müssen dann richtig
orientiert sein das ist klar
[Musik]
sollte es aktuell noch lose da drin
kommen jetzt dieser Gummi hier rein
und der hält nicht mehr aus Holz unten
sondern vor allem auch gleich das klar
drin so und da sieht er jetzt eigentlich
erstmal nur geil aus und dann
das filigranste die Zeiger hier muss ich
jetzt reinfriemeln ich fange mit dem
Stundenzeiger dann natürlich klar und zu
guter Letzt der Sekunde
gehe jetzt schon tickt ist ja krass das
Teil lebt einfach das ist heftig und das
krasseste hallo ich weiß nicht wieso ich
das so krass finde dass ich jetzt an
dieser Krone die Zeit einmal umstellen
kann und die dann wieder reinklicken
kann und dass sie dann weiter klickt
klar dass das funktioniert dieser
Mechanismus krass geiler scheiß dann
haben wir jetzt eine kleine Glasscheibe
und die setze ich jetzt mal rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das sind jetzt schlecht nein oh mann
Alter ja gut jetzt ungünstig ich war
eigentlich fertig aber ich wollte zu
viel
Alter
ja okay also ich brauche ein neues Glas
nur leider habe ich das nicht lassen zu
tun
jetzt nur noch die Griffe was Griffe so
und das Armband nicht aufgefallen
funktioniert
hier rein und ziehe ich den hier einmal
zurück
der sind beiden Löcher drin
so sehr aufdrehen und damit ist unsere
Uhr fertig ziehen wir mal an
und da ist er ist geil ich habe einfach
in Ruhe selber gemacht
crazy ist denn das das ist meine eigene
Uhr mit meinem eigenen Design selber
gemacht komplett geil ist auch nicht
unbequem also ich hatte erst eine Angst
dass das Teil der sticht aber das stört
überhaupt nicht crazy
[Musik]
ihr seht ihr jetzt gerade noch ein paar
photoshopte Bilder wie es aussehen würde
wenn ich keinen Vollidiot wäre den Link
zu Schub dem cashback-portal wo ihr beim
Onlineshopping Geld zurückbekommt findet
in der Videobeschreibung und ich bin
damit raus macht's gut